[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمول
وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من جنوب الخرطوم وسط
استمرار الاشتباكات واعلان الجيش السوداني
تعليق مشاركه في مفاوضات جده بسبب ما
اعتبره عدم التزام قوه الدعم السريع بشروط
الهدنه
والى واشنطن وجلسه تصويت في مجلس النواب
الامريكي حول اتفاق يتعلق برفع صف الدين
الامريكي تم التوصل اليه اثراء مفاوضات
مارادونيه
والى العاصمه المجريه بودابست ساحه
المشجعين بين شوطي المباراه النهائيه
لبطوله الدوري الاوروبي في كره القدم
يوروبا بين روما الايطالي واشبيليه
الاسبانيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[تصفيق]
واستشبكات في اندرمان والابيض ومواقع اخرى
الجيش السوداني يعلق مشاركته في مفاوضات
جده متهما قوات الدعم السريع بعدم الايثاء
بالتزاماتها البيت الابيض يصف قرار الجيش
بالامر المؤسف القائد الثاني للدعم السريع
يؤكد ان حمايه يقود المعارك من الصفوف
الاماميه والاتحاد الافريقي يعلن عن خريطه
طريق جديده لحل الصراع
في تطورات حرب اوكرانيا الهجمات تتزايد في
العمق الروسي الكريم يعرب عن القلق ينتقد
غياب ادانات الغرب ويلوح باتخاذ تدابير
دون الكشف عن تفاصيلها
ومستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه يقول للجزيره
ان روسيا تفقد السيطره على اجوائها في ظل
ازدياد الهجمات بالمسيرات
وسط تصاعد التوتر قوه حلف شمال الاطلس في
كوسوفو تواجه مئات المتظاهرين الصرب بعد
يومين من اشتباكات اصيب فيها العشرات
رئيس وزراء كوسوفو يتهم بلغراد بتاجيج
احتجاجات الاقليه الصربيه لزعزعه استقرار
بلاده ووزير دفاع صربيا يتفقد قواته على
الحدود والبيت الابيض يطالب اطراف الازمه
بخفض التوتر
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا قرار الجيش السوداني تعليق
المشاركه في مفاوضات جده بخصوص التطورات
في السودان لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
مات داعيات قرار الجيش السوداني تعليق
المشاركه في مفاوضات جدا
يرون ان ذلك يعني انتهاء جولات التفاوض
بجده بينما قال 18% انه سيكون توقفا مؤقتا
لمسار التفاوض فيما اعتبر سته واربعون في
المائه ان قرار الجيش قد يؤدي الى وضع
ترتيبات جديده للهدنه هذا سؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر
على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومت عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا بعد اتفاق على
رفع سقف الدين الامريكي اثراء مفاوضات
شاقه بدء تصويت حاسم في مجلس النواب
[موسيقى]
قال الجيش السوداني ان القياده العامه
للجيش قررت تعليق المشاركه في مفاوضات جده
بسبب ما اعتبره عدم التزام قوات الدعم
السريع بشروط الهدنه في هذه الاثناء دعا
القائد الثاني لقوه الدعم السريع عبد
الرحيم دقلو دعا الجيش للخروج على البرهان
وتنسيق مع قواته واضاف في خطاب مصور مع
قواته ان حميدتي بخير ويقاتل في الصفوف
الاماميه
منسحبون ليس من ميدان المعارك وانما من
المسار الذي كان يؤمل في اي ينهي القتال
ما الذي دفع الجيش السوداني وقائده عبد
الفتاح البرهان الى تعليق المشاركه في
مفاوضات جده
الله اكبر هو الشعب السوداني
انتجت تلك المفاوضات التي انطلقت قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع بواسطه امريكيه سعوديه جمله
من الهدد بين طرفي الصراع في السودان لم
تحترم
ذاك بالذات ما يقول الجيش السوداني انه
حرك قراره
فهو بخروجه عن مسار التفاوض انما يحتج على
هجمات يقول ان قوات الدعم السريع تشنها
على مواقعه في العاصمه والولايات
مقربون من البرهان وبقيه قيادات الجيش
تحدث ايضا عن انزعاجهم من غياب ضغط كاف
على قوه حميتي لحملها على الخروج من
الاحياء السكنيه والمشافي
الالتزام اذا هو المشكله لكل طرف هنا
روايته لكن المتقاتلين ملزمون كما يفترض
باعلان جده الذي من مبادئه عدم السعي
لتحقيق مكاسب على الارض خلال وقف اطلاق
النار
لا يسع احدا نفي استمرار القتال وان
تراجعت حدته في ظل اتفاق الهدنه الذي
استمر اسبوعا قبل ان يمدد العمل به لخمسه
ايام
لم تروا من هدنه في الوقت الراهن تسويه
سياسيه دائمه للصراع بل حركتها دواعي
انسانيه جعلت اولويتها حمايه المدنيين
وتامين ايصال المساعدات اليهم
هذا جهد يخشى ان يواجه مزيدا من التعقيد
مع خروج احد طرفي النزاع من دائره التفاوض
فماذا عن الطرف الاخر لن تشهد هنا خروجا
الى العلن على طريقه البرهان لايضاح
الموقف فليس القائد الاول لقوات الدعم
السريع ما يفعلها وانما شقيقه القائد
الثاني في تلك القوات الظاهر هنا مع رجاله
عبد الرحيم دعا قوات الجيش للخروج على
البرهان والتنسيق مع الدعم السريع كقوه
واحده وقال ان الدعم لن تقف مع عناصر
النظام السابق الذين يدين البرهان بالولاء
لهم حسب تعبيره
لكن ماذا عن حميدتي المتواري منذ فتره عن
الانظار يقول شقيقه انه بخير وانه يقاتل
في الصفوف الاماميه مع قواته
انا هنا في استديو الحصادي الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك
تعليق الجيش المشاركه بمفاوضات جده كيف
سينعكس هذا الامر على الميدان بشكل
اساسي من هذه القرار ان هناك ضغوطات
ممارسه على قياده الجيش من داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه ومن الجمهور العامه للمواطنين
لانه واضح ان هذه الهدن التي يتم الاعلان
عنها لا يتم الالتزام بها بالعكس تتواصل
عمليات النهب والسلب واحتلال المنازل
وتتواصل العمليات العسكريه في الهدنه
الاولى تم الهجوم على وادي سيدنا وهو مطار
مهم بالنسبه للجيش تم الهجوم على المدرعات
وفي الهدنه الثانيه تم الهجوم على
الاستراتيجيه وهي موقع مهم وحساس بالنسبه
للجيش كذلك كانوا هنالك هجوم على العمله
مطابع العمله فمع كل هذه الهدن المعلنه
تقوم تقوم قوات الدعم السريع بالهجوم على
مواقع لكن هناك كلام
المقابل للدعم السريع ان العكس هو الذي
يحصل انه مع كل هدنه الجيش هو الذي لا
يلتزم وهو الذي
يقصف مواقع قوات الدعم الساريه لا نعتقد
ان الجيش يدرك بان هنالك رقابه خاصه ان
هناك رقابه عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه فهو لا
يتجاوز هذا الامر بشكل طبيعي الا اذا كان
هنالك اختراقات وهذه الاختراعات يتم
التعبير عنها من قبل القوات الدعم السريع
حينما تعلن بانها سيطرت على العمله وحينما
يتم الاكتشاف بانها تتجه نحو مطار وادي
سيدنا ونحن المدرعات فما هو المراد من
الجيش في التعامل مع هذه التهديدات
الخطيره التي تستهدف مواقع استراتيجيه هل
الان انتهت مفاوضات جده برايك ربما تقوم
معلقه ربما ان هنالك مساحه اوسع الان
لعمليات عسكريه يبدو ان الجيش عازم على
خوضها في الفتره القادمه خاصه وان البرهان
في ظهوري الاخير هدد بان هنالك خيار
استخدام القوه المميته فيما يتعلق
هذه الم فاوضات وهذه الهدن انما هي برعايه
سعوديه امريكيه الى اي مدى يمكن
للطرفين ان يقفزوا فوق هذه
الحقيقه الحقائق الواقع هي التي تفرض
منطقها على الطرفين والحقائق الميدانيه
وليس هنالك اليات ضابطه وحاسمه لهذه
لمراقبه هذه الهدى الصحيح هنالك حديث عن
الاستعمال الاعمار الاصطناعيه ولكن يبدو
ان
هذه الهدن كانت في حاجه لاليات اكثر دقه
لضبط التحركات
وخيارات كذلك حينما تطالب القوات الدعم
السريع بالانسحاب من الاعيان المدنيه لابد
ان تحدد اماكن اخرى لا تستطيع ان تعود الى
ذات الاماكن التي كانت عليها ولا تستطيع
ان تخرج الى الفضاء لانها ستتعرض لقصف من
القبل الجيش فبالتالي كان الاولى ان يكون
هنالك ترتيب موثوق به
لانسحاب قوات الدعم السريع من الاعيان
المدنيه هو الدعم السريع اليوم تدعو الجيش
الى الخروج على
والتنسيق معها كما قال شقيق
محمد حمدان حميدتي الذي شقيقه الذي قال ان
حميدتي بخير نعم ربما ان الجمهور والراية
العام مع تكاثر هذه الشائعات والاحاديث
الكثيره عن الوضع الخاص كان يجب ان يتم
نفي هذا هذه الشيائعات المتعدده او
المعلومات الناقصه بظهور حمدي
لا ظهور شقيقه اعتقد ان ذلك كان معطى مهم
اما الدعوه للانحياز للدعم السريع اعتقد
انها كانت رهانات اليوم الاول او رهانات
الساعات الاولى كان يتوقع الدعم السريع
انه بهذه العمليه العسكريه الخاطفه
الانقلابيه الخاطفه سيحدث انشقاق داخل
الجسم وستعلن مجموعات وقيادات ربما تم
التنسيق مع بعضها للانحياز للدعم السريع
ولكن هذه الرهانات السبت مع الايام ثبت مع
الايام بان هذه الرهانات الرهانات خاصه
وفاشله لم تتحقق فبالتالي ما لم يتحقق في
الساعات الاولى ايام الصدمه والرعب لا
اعتقد انه سيتحقق والدعم السريعي يلتجي
الى المنازل ويلتجئ الى المستشفيات ويتخذ
هذه الخيارات شكرا جزيلا لك الدين بلال
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
اعرب منسق للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي عن اسفه
لتعليق القوات المسلحه السودانيه المشاركه
في مفاوضات جده ودعا كيربي القوات المسلحه
السودانيه الى اغتنام فرصه السلام بشكل
جاد
[موسيقى]
هذا امر مؤسف نريد ان يتوقف القتال وان
تدخل المساعدات من الصعب ان تصل هذه
المساعدات الى الخرطوم وجميع انحاء البلاد
لمن هم في امس الحاجه الى الغذاء والدواء
من المؤسف للغايه ان تختار القوات المسلحه
لانسحاب من المفاوضات نريدها ان تغتنم
فرصه السلام ونحن جادون ونسهل المحادثات
ونريدها ان تتصرف وفقا لذلك
معنى
نائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابق للشؤون الافريقيه والمستشاره
السابقا للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى
السودان
سيده بيج كلام كيربي هل فيه تحميل مسؤوليه
لاحداث قادمه في السودان
للجيش والقوات المسلحه بقياده البرهان
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الدعوه الكريمه بحسب
فهم ان وزاره الخارجيه انتقدت كلا الطرفين
انتقدت قوات الدعم السريع من جهه
والقوات المسلحه من جهه اخرى
لتعليق التفاوض بشان
الاحداث التي كانت تجري في السودان
وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان الوزاره تلوم طرف
دون الاخر
طيب الان كيف تنظر الولايات المتحده برايك
الى هذا التعليق تعليق الجيش المشاركه في
مفاوضات جده والتي عللها الجيش بان قوات
الدعم السريع لم تلتزم بالهدن السابقه حتى
الان
[موسيقى]
ان اتحدث بالنيابه عن الحكومه الامريكيه
ولكن وفقا لما اعرفه هناك محاوله تجري
الان لاعاده الطرفين على المسار التفاوضي
او الى المسار التفاوضي وهناك جهود تبذل
بالمشاركه مع حكومه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لكي يعود الجيش الى طاوله
المفاوضات
كيف يمكن هنا للولايات المتحده ان تفرض
على قوات الدعم السريع الالتزام
بالهدن التي تعلن برعايتها وبرعايه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لست متاكده بنسبه الى كيفيه فرض هذا الامر
من ضمن السؤال ولكن بالنسبه الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبالنسبه الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هناك جهود تركز على وقف
الاعمال العدائيه من اجل ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه وهذا يكتسب طابعا مهما للغايه
بالنسبه الى الشعب السوداني الذي لا يزال
عالقا في مدن مختلفه ليس فقط في الخرطوم
وام درمان بل في مناطق قواوي ولايات اخرى
في كل انحاء السودان كيف تفهمين
غياب قائد قوات الدعم السريع حماتي عن
المشهد
وكيف يمكن
بهذه الحال ان يكون قرار هذه القوات موحدا
في غياب قائديها حتى الان
متاكده مما تعنيه بالنسبه الى ما تقوله
حول غياب احميتي لا اعرف اذا ما كانت
لربما هذه الطريق مرتبطه
بالتكتيكات من ناحيه اخرى هناك موقف
البرهان الذي يتم الترقب بشانه ولكن هناك
الكثير من الفوضى على اي حال في السودان
ومن غير الواضح من يقود ماذا ومن وهناك
عدد من المنظمات الاخرى وهناك وكالات
ومؤسسات حكوميه السودانيه باضافه الى
الوكالات الاخرى التي تحركت من
المكان التي كانت فيه وبالتالي لست متاكده
بالنسبه الى غياب حميتي ولكن المفاوضات
التي كانت تجري كانت تجري مع ممثل حماتي
من جهه وايضا ممثل الجيش بقياده الجنرال
البرهان يؤخذ هنا على الولايات المتحده في
هذا المجال انها
عند التوصل الى تلك الهدن الميدانيه تحت
عنوان انساني لم تخلق لها اليات واضحه ولم
يكن هناك مراقبه جديه لمن يخرق هذه الهدى
وبالتالي هذا امر جعلها غير صامده وجعلها
تخترق في اكثر من مكان ما الذي منع
الولايات المتحده من وضع اليات صارمه
لمراقبه هذه الهدن
الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن مفاوضات تجري في جده
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
برعايه الحكومه الامريكيه والحكومه
السعوديه ونحن لا نتحدث عن طرف واحد
باستطاعته ان يقوم بكل شيء حتى ولو كان
الطرف الوسيط يتعين على طرفي النزاع الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع ان يحترماه ما يتم
التوصل بشانه في
المفاوضات وبالتالي هذه هي المشكله
المشكله هي عدم احترام الاليات وليس غياب
الاليات وبالاضافه الى ذلك هناك عدد من
المراقبين السودانيين على المستوى المحلي
قاموا بمراقبه الهدنه والهدن المتتاليه
وقاموا برفع التقارير بشان وقف الاعمال
العدائيه وبالتالي هذه التقارير يتم
الركود اليها بالنسبه الى ما يشاهدونه في
الميدان هناك عدد كبير من شهود العيان
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه اعلنتا عن تقارير تحدثت
فيهما عن خلق
لوقف العمل شكرا لك
جنائبه مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق لشؤون الافريقيه
من جانب قال محمد الحسن ولد لبات مدير
ديوان الاتحاد الافريقي للجزيره ان اجتماع
الاليات الموسعه الذي عطل في اديس ابابا
اتفق على خريطه طريق جديده لحل الازمه
السودانيه وتشدد الاليه الموسعه على منع
التدخل الخارجي في شؤون السودانيه وتنسيق
الاجراءات الدوليه ومنع اي مبادرات تقلل
من العمل المشترك وتتضمن خريطه الطريق
الافريقيه استئناف العمليه السياسيه
لاستكمال للانتقال السياسي الذي توقف بسبب
الصراع
هذا الاجتماع وافق على خارطه الطريق
الافريقيه التي اساسها العمل بساعي
المختلفه من اجل وقف اطلاق النار في اسرع
ما يكون واذا وبالتالي تاييد مسار جده بين
الذي تشرف عليه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والسعوديه والذي نضمنه
وثانيا ان
يقام بعمل واسع ومتشعب لكل وكالات الغذاء
لاغاده الانسانيه من اجل ان تصل المساعدات
والاغاثه للسكان في مختلف مناطق السودان
[موسيقى]
الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا تصعد متواصل
ولافت في العمق الروسي اخر معالمه في
الساعه الاخيره هجمات واسعه بالمسيرات
تستهدف مقاطعات روسيه عده روسيا وان كانت
تتهمكيات بتنفيذ هذه الضربات فانها تحمل
المسؤوليه لداعميها الغربيين واليهم تتوجه
بالوعيد
حرب المسيرات على جانبي الحدود مرحله
جديده تدخلها المعارك بين كييف وموسكو ذاك
ما كان جليا في تصاعد هجمات الطائرات
المسيره على اهداف داخل الاراضي الروسيه
بالجرود جنوب غربي روسيا لا تكاد تنطفئ
نيران الهجمات هنا حتى تشتعل مجددا فخلال
يوم واحد فقط ضربت 155 قذيفه منطقه
الشبكيينو في مقاطعه بيلجرود ومن اقوى
هجمات الساعات الاخيره تلك التي استهدفت
مصفاه لتكرير النفط في اقليم كراش نودار
في جنوب روسيا لا تبعد كثيرا عن ميناء
نوفروسيسك الروسي على البحر الاسود حيث
هاجم الطائره المسيره مصفاه لتكرير النفط
غرب مدينه كرست ندار عاصمه الاقليم ما ادى
لاندلاع حريق بمضخه للديزل على مساحه 100
متر مربع مسيره ثانيه حاولت ضرب منشاه
السكي لتكرير النفط غرب مدينه كريستودار
ايضا
لكنها اسقطت قبل بلوغ وجهتها بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وسبق ان تعرضت منشاته
النفطيه هذه لاكثر من ثلاث هجمات بمسيارات
خلال شهر مايو وفي هجوم اوسع هاجمت عشر
طائرات مسيره منطقه كليموفيسك بمقاطعه
بيريانسك الروسيه المتخيمه للحدود مع
اوكرانيا تقول السلطات المقاطعه ان محطات
الرادار الالكترونيه اسقطت عددا من
المسيرات المهاجمه وبالتزامن مع هجوم
المسيرات تتعرض نقطه تفتيش حدوديه في
مقاطعه بيريانس لهجوم مسلح حدث ذلك تحديدا
عند حاجز بروج الحدودي لعبور السيارات
تتهم السلطاتك المواليه لروسيا القوات
الاوكرانيه بانها من قامت باطلاق النار
هذه الهجمات تاتي بعد ساعات من هجوم غير
مسبوق في حجمه شانه سرب من ثماني طائرات
مسيره على العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وخلافا
لجميع هذه الهجمات كان هجوم الثالث من
مايو اكثرها خطوره اذ اعلنت السلطات
الروسيه اسقاط طائرتين مسيرتين خلال
محاولتهما مهاجمه هذا الهجوم كان فاتحه
لهجمات شبه يوميه في العمق الروسي منذ
بدايه مايو برا وجوا 100 كييف بنفسها عن
معظم هذه الهجمات مشيره الى انها بفعل
جماعات مناوئه للكرملين وفقا لما تعلنه
السلطات في موسكو فان الطائرات من دون
طيار من طراز يوجي 22 تشن جل الهجمات فهي
سلاح مفضل لمهاجمه اهداف روسيه بعيدا عن
ميدان المعركه في اوكرانيا تصنع هذه
الطائرات في اوكرانيا ومداها يصل الى 800
كيلومتر ما يجعلها قادره على الوصول الى
موسكو وما وراءها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تتحدث كذلك عن هجمات بالطائرات المسيره
البريطانيه من طراز 150 وهي طائرات
تستخدمها مشاه البحريه الملكيه البريطانيه
يمكنها حمل حتى 68 كيلو جراما وتستطيع
الطيران حتى 70 كيلومترا تدخل صواريخ
ستورم شادو البريطانيه اتون الحرب وقد
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط عدد
منها دون ان تفصح عن تفاصيل مكان الهجوم
يبلغ مدى ستورم شادو اكثر من 250 كيلومترا
وتتميز بقدراتها على تدمير اي هدف تصيبه
بدقه اما في عمليات التوغل البري فكان
لافتا حضور المدرعات المضاده للكمائن
والالغام امراب الامريكيه الصنع والتي
ظهرت خلال هجوم بري نفدته قوات مواليه
لكييف داخل الاراضي الروسيه وفقا لوسائل
اعلام روسيه صنعت مركبه امراب للمره
الاولى لخدمه القوات الامريكيه في العراق
وافغانستان وزودت الولايات المتحده الجيش
الاوكراني بعده مئات منها
وقال الكريم لان موسكو لم تسمع اي ادانه
من الدول الغربيه بشان هجوم المسيرات على
العاصمه الروسيه وعرب الكريم عن قلقه من
عمليات قصف بالجوروت قائلا ان سلاح الجو
الروسي يعمل بشكل فعال لكن هناك مجال
لتحسين وقال انه يجري حاليا اتخاذ تدابير
من دون تقديم تفاصيل اضافيه
وكنت قد اجريت مقابله مع ميخيل كبير
مستشري الرئيس الاوكراني وسالته عن علاقه
اوكرانيا بالهجمات بالمسيرات داخل روسيا
نشات بما يحدث في روسيا تعلمون اننا في
اوضاع الحرب منذ خمسه عشر شهر وما تقوم به
روسيا تقوم بالكثير من الاعمال العدوانيه
ولكن الحرب بتدريج تنتقل الى الاراضي
الروسيه لان هذه الحرب بهذه المساحه سوف
تنقلب عليهم لم يحاولوا حل المسائل بطريقه
سلميه اليوم ننظر كيف
تزداد وسائل الهجمات على روسيا بالمسيرات
طبعا ليس لاوكرانيا اي صله مباشره بهذه
الاحداث نحن ننظر لها بايجابيه من وجهه
نظر التنظيم هذه امور منظمه داخليا على
اراضي روسيه وروسيا تفقد السيطره على
مناطقها وتفقد
النظام وهذه الهجمات تزيد اثرها ويزيد
عددها ولكن
حصل المعلومات الروسيه هذه الطائرات
المستخدمه الطائرات المسيره المستخدمه في
الهجمات هي من صنع اوكراني
كلا هذا ليس كذلك انهم لم يصنعوا اوكرانيا
انها مسيرات صغيره لا تطير لمسافات طويله
وانطلقت من مناطق محيطه لموسكو
واظهرت هذه الهجمات ان روسيا
ليست بالحجم والقدرات التي تعلن عنها ليس
لديها انظمه قويه
للدفاعات الجويه وليست لديها قدرات دفاع
الكترونيه ليس لديهم قدره على السيطره على
هذه المسيرات فلقد انطلقت من مواقع محيطه
لموسكو واظهرت نقاط الضعف حول موسكو
وحمايه موسكو لم يستطيعوا ان يتعاملوا مع
مسيرات بهذه البساطه عمليا هل لديكم اي
علاقه او معرفه او ارتباط بالمنفذين حتى
لو لم يكونوا اوكرانيين هل انتم على علم
بمن ينفذ هذه الهجمات داخل روسيا
نعلم ان هناك الكثير من المواطنين الروس
الذين بداوا بتشكيل مجموعات معارضه مسلحه
مثل فيلق روسيا الحره او ارض كا هذه
المجموعات كثيره في روسيا ونحن نعرفها
ونعرف الكثيرين من المواطنين الروس الذين
مستعدون للقيام
بمعارضه مسلحه ضد النظام الروسي هناك
الكثير الكثير من هذه المجموعات وعددها في
تزايد وسوف يظهرون في مختلف المناطق
الروسيه والسبب
ان الحكومه وبوتين خسر سمعته وكل من يحيط
به ولان العمود
عفوا اذا اذا
كنتم اذا كنتم تعرفونهم جيدا هل انتم
مستعدون
لدعمهم
عسكريا وذل الادوات التي يحتاجونها من اجل
ان يشنوا هجماتهم داخل روسيا
اولا نحن لا نعلم كل من هو مستعد للهجمات
في الداخل الروسي من المواطنين هم يظهروا
بشكل متدرج من جانب اخر هم مستعدين لان
يحصلوا على او قادرين على الحصول على
مختلف الوسائل الضروريه للعمليات من
الجانب الثالث سوف نرحب باي ظواهر
للمعارضات الداخليه في روسيا
لن نتدخل طبعا في الاعمال التي يقوم بها
هؤلاء المواطنين الذين يعرضون نظام بوتين
لكننا لدينا هدف واحد هو تدمير القوات
العسكريه
المتواجده على اراضنا وسوف نستخدم كل
الوسائل لهذا سيد بدوياك روسيا اعلنت
اليوم عن تدمير اخر سفينه حربيه اوكرانيه
ما تعليقكم على هذا الاعلان
ان شاء الله
اذكركم بدايه الحرب في بدايه
العمليات العسكريه قال الوزير وزير الدفاع
عنه دمر الاسطول البحري الاوكراني والان
نحن 31 من مايو عام 23 وهم يقولون انهم
دمروا سفينه حربيه ان روسيا لا تعلن اي
معلومات حقيقيه هذا شيء معروف ان روسيا
تغذب باستمرار لا اعلم لماذا تقوم بعد
الدول وحتى الدول العربيه بالانصات لما
تقوله روسيا روسيا لا تتحدث عن الحقيقه
اما نحن نريد ان اقول ان اسطولنا البحريه
بخير وهو يقوم بكل المهمات الضروريه اين
اصبح الهجوم
المضاد هجوم الربيع قد انقض الربيع ونحن
على ابواب فصل الصيف ما هي العقبات التي
تحول دون شنه
اريد ان اوضح امور بسيطه جدا ضروريه لفهم
هذه الحرب هذه الحرب حرب مركزه ينضم لها
مئات الالاف من الجنود وهناك عشرات الالاف
من اليات الحرب منها الطائرات والمدفعيات
والمدرعات ليس هناك خطه
مرتبطه بتاريخ معين للقيام ببعض
العمليات الخاصه ان العامل الاساسي هنا هو
تجميع المعدات الضروريه للقيام بتقدم في
مختلف الجبهات
هجمات ممكن ان تكون مكونه من مختلف الجنود
مئات مئات الالاف منهم ايضا عوامل الطقس
يعمل
هنا الطقس هذا عامل مهم لان موسم الشتاء
كان طويل جدا
والرط التربه
لا تمنع المعدات من التقدم اما بالنسبه
لتخطيط السيناريو سيناريو الهجمات الذي
يعمل عليه الهيئه العسكريه العليا هذا شيء
اخر ان اوكرانيا تحاول تدمير الخطوط
الخلفيه للعدو حتى تمنعه من مد قواته
بالذخيره ولذلك نحن نقوم بضربات مدفعيه
على الخطوط الخلفيه نقصف المستودعات وخطوط
المد ومراكز تجمع القوات العسكريه كل هذا
يدمر يدمر الان حتى نقلل قدرات الجيش
الروسي
وينضم الينا من موسكو يافديني فيدوروف عضو
مجلس الدومه الروسي مرحبا بك سيد افقيني
اذا
كما تبعت مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني يقول ان
روسيا تفقد السيطره على اجوائها وهي
والحرب قد اصبحت على اراضيها
مرضك على ذلك
[موسيقى]
هذه افكار تعتبر من العطب ان روسيا هي
دوله نوويه ولديها قدرات عسكريه اكثر من
اوكرانيا بعشر مرات تعداد الجنود والمعدات
هذا وان لم نتكلم عن القدرات النوويه لكن
اذا تحدثنا عن القدرات النوويه فان روسيا
لديها قدره على تدمير جميع الدول
الاوروبيه بالقدرات النوويه اما القدرات
الاستراتيجيه الدمويه فبامكاننا ان ندمر
الولايات المتحده
ان روسيا اضمن لكم هذا سوف تنتصر في هذا
النزاع ان هذه رياضيات بسيطه وحساب بسيط
ليس المهمه يحدث الان في الاعمال العسكريه
من هذا النزاع المهم بماذا سينتهي هذا
النزاع
عن التصعيد والاهداف تصبح الاهداف الان
اصبحت ابعد بكثير من اوكرانيا لانه من
المفهوم ان اوكرانيا لا تحارب بنفسها بل
اوروبا والولايات المتحده هي من تحارب
لذلك نحن نقوم بتحضير لامور لم يتوقعها
احد يجب ان نقوم بالقضاء على هذه الدوله
الغير قانونيه لم يكن لدينا مثل هذه
الاهداف ان التصعيد من ياتي بنتائج عكسيه
وسوف
نقوم بالوصول لهذه الاهداف
واعتقد اننا علينا بالتعاون مع الصين
ومختلف الدول ان نقضي على النظام
الواقع تحت
الامريكيه
روسيا لديها امكانيه
عذرا عذرا للمقاطعه لاننا لاننا نود ان
نستثهم حول ما قلت
تقول وطبعا انت تقول ذلك ردا على مالت
اليه الاوضاع حتى الان في هذه الحرب تقول
ان روسيا تقوم بالتحضير لامور لن او لم
يتوقعها احد واشرت الى
مشاركه او تعاون مع الصين حول هذه الامور
بالتحديد ما الذي تحضر له روسيا وهو خارج
عن المالوف كما تقول الان
قلت ان روسيا تقوم بتغيير الاهداف في ضوء
التغيير والتصعيد في اثناء العمليات
العسكريه هذه الاهداف تتغير ليس لاننا نحن
من نريد هذا ولكن لان الظروف تضطر لهذا
اذا كان النزاع ضيقا في القطاع حيث النزاع
لكن الان تنضم الهند والصين
تنضم للنزاع وتقوم بتدمير النظام الامريكي
وتحوله الى نظام متعدد القطبيه والكثير من
الدول مثل الدول العربيه تنضم لهذا الحلف
لان الكثيرين مهتمين
بنظام جديد نحن نريد تغيير وتجديد النظام
العالمي
ويجب ان نؤسس لنظام متعدد الاقطاب على
اساس شكرا
من موسكو عضو مجلس الدوم الروسي
[موسيقى]
التوتر يتصاعد في كوسوفو قوه النيتو تواجه
مئات المتظاهرين الصرب بعد يومين من
اشتباكات اصيب فيها العشرات اتهام من
برشتينو
وبينما تفقد وزير الدفاع دفاع صربيا قوته
على الحدود طلب البيت الابيض اطراف الازمه
بخفض التوتر
جنود من الناتو مصابون كسور وحروق وجروح
خطره في مواجهات مع محتجين صرب شماليه
كوسوفو
مشاهد اعتبرت قياده حلف شمال الاطلسي انه
لا يمكن التساهل معها فاعلنت ارسال 700
جندي اضافي لتعزيز قواتها
جنود الناتو ابطال في عيون البان كوسوفو
فلولا النيتو لكانت كوسوفو قد انتهت لذلك
هذه اخبار ساره لكن الكسوليين لديهم ايمان
بشرطه بلدهم والمشكله في الواقع بشان
البلديات الاربع هي مع شرطه كوسوفو لان
وجودها هناك يثبت سياده الدوله
وسع جنود القوه الدوليه المعروفه بكيفور
نطاق السياج الامني في محيط مقر البلديات
المتنازع عليها لكن الود بين الناتو
وحكومه كوسوفو ليس في احسن مستوياته فقد
الغى الحلف بقرار امريكي مشاركه برشتينا
في مناورات
ردا على التصعيد الاخير
هذه المشكله بسبب سياسات الماضي والقضيه
كان يجب ان تحل منذ وقت طويل كل العالم
يعرف صربيا نحن نامل بعون الله ثم حلفائنا
ان تتحسن الظروف
صربيا غير راضيه عن هذه القوات تقول انها
ساعدت شرطه كوسوفو على احتلال شمال
الاقليم وتجاوزت نطاق واجباتها
عالمي يكرهنا وخاصه الالبان يريدون قتلنا
جميعا امريكا تحدث الفوضى هنا ونحن سنخسر
ابنائنا الى اين يريدوننا ان نذهب نحن هنا
منذ الاف السنين هذه كلها صربيا
اكد ان قواته ستظل نزيهه ومحايده تحفظ امن
الجميع بعيدا عما وصفها بالروايات الكاذبه
للطرفين
تزيد عدد هؤلاء الجنود للمره الاولى منذ
نحو عقد بعد ان اعطت السنوات القليله
الماضيه احساسا زائفا في نظر كثيرين
بتراجع التوترات زياده في الاعداد يريد
الحلف ان تبعث برسائل طمانه الى الداخل
ولكن فيها تاكيد منه ايضا وفق مراقبين بان
الناتو سيبقى عامل الاستقرار الاول في
البلقان محمد المدهون الجزيره من بلده
زفيد شام شماليه
[موسيقى]
بدا مجلس النواب الامريكيه التصويت على
الاتفاق المبرم بين رئيس المجلس كيف
ماكافي والرئيس جو بايدن بشان سقف الدين
ومن المتوقع ان ينال مشروع القانون موافقه
المجلس رغم معارضه بعض النواب الجمهوريين
وفي حال تمريره يحال الى مجلس الشيوخ
لتصويت عليه في وقت لاحق من الاسبوع
هذه صور مباشره
لمجلس النواب الامريكيه حيث التصويت على
اتفاق رفع سقف الدين ومن مقر الكونجرس
معنا محمد العلمي مراسل الجزيره ليحدثنا
عن اجواء التصويت والارقام المتوقعه
والنتيجه المفترضه بعد الاتفاق محمد
نعم حسن اجواء تعكس الضغوط التي تخيم على
هذه الجلسه بعد او قبل ايام قليله على
تحضير الذي اطلقته وزيره الخيزنه
الامريكيه بان الولايات المتحده لن تستطيع
الوفاء بالتزاماتها الماليه في الخامس من
الشهر المقبل او هذا الشهر تقريبا
بتوقيتكم اذا لم يتم رفع سقف الديون
الخارجيه الان التصويت النهائي على مشروع
القانون هنا في مجلس النواب ما زال بعيدا
حوالي اربع ساعات من الان لكن بدا واضحا
طبيعه النتيجه النهائيه الان من خلال
التصويت اجرائي
يسمح مجلس النواب لنفسه
بمناقشه مشروع القانون عاده هذا التصويت
الاجرائي
تنحصر فيه الموافقه على حزب الاغلبيه اي
حزب الرئيس لكن
بسبب وجود اغلبيه مش اغلبيه عقليه يمينيه
متشدده داخل الحزب الجمهوري انشقت على
الرئيس
وتعارض معارضه شديده مشروع القانون هذا
لانه من وجهه نظرها لم يقدم ما تتطلع اليه
من تخفيضات في الميزانيه العامه فحاولت
نسخ المشروع القانون حتى قبل ان يعرض على
التصويت بعد اربع ساعات من الان لكن
الديمقراطيين هبوا لمساعده خصمهم اللدود
كيف المقاصي وصوت 50 مشرعا ديمقراطيا
لفائده هذا الاجراء
السماح بالنقاش العام لانه بعد
ان 29 مشرعا جمهوريا عن حزبهم وعن رئيسهم
كان من الممكن نظريا على الاقل اقبار
مشروع القانون هنا في مجلس النواب لانك
ذلك كان سيحول دون عرضه على المجلس ككل
لولا مساعده الديمقراطيين بخمسين مشرعا
وهذا السيناريو من المتوقع ان يتكرر بعد
حوالي اربع ساعات من الان حينما يعرض
مشروع القانون على التصويت على باقي اعضاء
مجلس النواب شكرا لك محمد العلمي مراسل
الجزيره من مقر الكونغرس
نقلت شبكه سي ان ان نعم مصادر قولها ان
الادعاء الفيدرالي حصل على تسجيل صوتي
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترند اقر فيه بانه
يحتفظ بوثيقه سريه للبينتاجون حول هجوم
محتمل ضد ايران وافادت الشبكه بان التسجيل
الصوتي يشير الى ان ترامب كان يدرك انه
احتفظ بمستندات سريه بعد مغادرته البيت
الابيض وذلك وفقا لمصادر مطلعه على
التحضير الذي تجريه وزاره العدل حول
المستندات السريه التي كان يحتفظ بها في
مارلاجو بولايه فلوريدا
رفضت مصلحه السجون الاسرائيليه بحث طلب
الافراج المبكر عن الاسير وليد دقه المصاب
بنوع خطير من مرض السرطان رغم حالته
الصحيه الحرجه واعتبرت عائله الاسير
الفلسطيني القرار رضوخا لحمله تحريض
قادتها جهات اسرائيليه متطرفه
كان يفترض ان يشاركها بابا وليد كما تعرفه
عبر لقاءات السجن البارده هذه الاوقات وهي
التي ولدت كمعجزه من نطفه مهربه من داخل
السجن انه احنا ولا مره التقينا ولا مره
سمحولنا انه نتصور مع بعض بس
عملنا صوره انه مع بعض بنتامل تصير حقيقه
فمنذ اشهر انتهت محكوميه الاسير وليد دقه
بالسجن 37 عاما لكن اضيف له عامان اخران
لتبدو هذه المده اصعب مما مضى فقد اصيب
اخيرا بنوع نادر من امراض السرطان انا ما
بدي انه افكر يعني انه النهايه بدها تكون
لا سمح الله هيك انا مؤمنه بوليد وليد
مقاتل واكيد راح يتجاوز هاي المحنه يعد
وليد احد ابرز الاسرى القدامى وقد انتج
العديد من والمقالات عن معنى حياه الاسر
في سجون الاحتلال في الاونه الاخيره
تدهورت حالته الصحيه ونقل الى العنايه
المكثفه
[تصفيق]
ولانقاذ حياته تطالب عائلته بالافراج
الفوري عنه لكن جهات اسرائيليه عده تطالب
بابقائه في الاسر حتى الموت رغم انه
المناضل وليد دق انها محكوميته بدهم
عندهم روح الانتقام هي بنيويه في نفسيتهم
تربويه وتربيتهم تستجيب مصلحه السجون
لمطلب هؤلاء وتحيل قضيته الى لجنه اخرى
تقول العائله انه قرار باعدامه فبينما
يخوض وليد معركه قد تكون الاخيره يسلب
السجان منه زمنا ثمينا اخر قد يعني هذه
المره حرمانه من اخر احلامه
ان يحتضن ابنته ميلاد
38 عاما في الاسر وقت لا يحسب بمفهومه
الاعتيادي بل بالزمن الموازي كما سماه
الاسير وليد الدقه ورغم شده قسوه هذا
الزمن تطلب المؤسسه الاسرائيليه ما هو
اقصى من ذلك انتقاما من الاسرى
ومطالبتهم بالحريه
نجوان سمري الجزيره من امام سجن الرملي
داخل الخط الاخضر
بينما هي لم تتعافى اصلا من عوامل توتر
سابقه حدث ما يمكن ان يدفع بالعلاقات
الصينيه الامريكيه نحو الاسوا بالنسبه
للجيش الامريكي فان هذا الفيديو يوافق
ملابسات الحادث الجوي في سماء بحر جنوب
الصين وفي التفاصيل ان مقاتله صينيه نفذت
يوم الجمعه الماضي مناوره اعتراض وصفها
بالعدوانيه امام طائره استطلاع امريكيه
كانت في مهمه الروتينيه فوق بحر جنوب
الصين في المجال الجوي الدولي ردا على تلك
الروايه اكد الجيش الصيني وقوع الحادث
لكنه قدم روايه مغايره قائلا ان طائره
الاستطلاع الامريكيه توغلت عمدا في منطقه
تدريب عسكري للاسطول السابع عشر للبحريه
الصينيه فارسل الجيش طائره لتعقب الطائره
الامريكيه بما يتوافق مع القوانين
والقواعد
وتعقيبا على الحادث
والاتهامات المضاده من ساسه في البلدين
كثيرا ما ارسلت الولايات المتحده سفنا
وطائرات مقاتله لاجراء استطلاع بالقرب من
الصين ما يعرض السياده الوطنيه وامنها
للخطر هذه الاعمال الاستفزازيه والخطيره
هي السبب الجذري لقضايا الامن البحري يجب
على امريكا ان توقف على الفور مثل هذه
الاعمال وسنواصل اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لحمايه سيادتنا وامننا بحزم
كانت طائرتنا تحلق في المجال الجوي الدولي
في مهمه الروتينيه اتخذ الطيار الصيني
اجراءات خطيره في الاقتراب من الطائره لقد
كانت هناك سلسله من هذه الاجراءات موجهه
ليست فقط الينا ولكن الى دول اخرى في
الاشهر الاخيره اعتقد ان هذا يؤكد سبب
اهميه وجود خطوط اتصال منتظمه ومفتوحه بما
في ذلك بين وزراء دفاعنا من المؤسف ان
الاجتماع الذي سع هذه الوزير اوستن لم
يمضي قدما مع نظيره الصيني الاجتماع الذي
ذكره بلينكن هو ذاك الذي رفضت الصين تلبيه
دعوه امريكيه لعقده هذا الاسبوع في
سنغافوره بين وزيريه دفاع البلدين وتقول
بيجين ان الولايات المتحده مسؤوله عن
صعوبات التواصل بين الجيشين لانها تتجاهل
مخاوف الصين وتفتعل العقبات والاربعاء
تفقد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
قاعدتين عسكريتين لبلاده في اليابان واثنى
على دور الجنود في الحفاظ على ما سماها
حريه التجاره والافكار في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ معتبرا الوجود العسكري
الامريكيه هناك راس حربه في مواجهه الصين
ترى هل يدفع الحادث الجديد البلدين
لاستشعار الخطر ومن ثم العمل على احتواء
التوتر بينهما ام تسوء العلاقات اكثر فاك
ثر مدفوعه برواسب الماضي القريب من حادث
سقوط المنطاد الصيني على الاراضي
الامريكيه وقبلها وبعدها قضيه تايوان
والحرب التجاريه فضلا عن اتهام واشنطن
لبيجين بالسعي لتزويد روسيا بالاسلحه خلال
حربها على اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الان مشاهدينا الى كوريا الشماليه ومحاوله
فاشله لاطلاق قمر اصطناعي للتجسس تسببت في
حاله ارتباك في كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
وردود فعل غاضبه فما الذي حدث
قلت وكاله الانباء الكوريه الشماليه
الرسميه ان الصاروخ الفضائيه الجديد
تشيولينا واحد تحطم في البحر الغربي وهو
الاسم الكوري للبحر الاصفر مبرره هذا
الفشل بعدم استقرار المحرك ونظام الوقود
واعلن الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ان المقذوف
الكوري الشماليه اختفى من على شاشات
الرادار قبل ان يصل الى نقطه سقوطه
المتوقع ونشر الجيش الكوري الجنوبي صورا
لانتشال حطام قمر الاستطلاع الاصطناعي
العسكري من البحر على بعد 200 كيلومتر غرب
جزيره ايو شيونج التي تقع قباله الساحل
الغربي لكوريا الجنوبيه
ما حدث في الساعات الاخيره يعد سادس
محاولات
لاطلاق قمر صناعي والاولى لها منذ عام
2016 كان من المفترض ان تضع اول قمر صناعي
للتجسس تطلقه كوريا الشماليه في مداره
تسببت المحاوله الفاشله لاطلاق كوريا
الشماليه قمرا صناعيا عسكريا تسبب في
اطلاق صافرات الانذار في انحاء سول كافه
في وقت مبكر من الصباح كما اصدرت الحكومه
اليابانيه تحذيرا طارئا لسكان مقاطعه
اوكينا والجنوبيه وطلبت منهم الاحتماء
داخل منازلهم
عموما
المحاوله الكوريه الشماليه الفاشله سلطت
الضوء مجددا على الفروق بين تقنيه
المستخدمه في كل من عمليات اطلاق الاقمار
الصناعيه والصواريخ الباليسيه العابره
للقارات يتطلب ارسال الاقمار الاصطناعيه
الى الفضاء واطلاق الصواريخ الباليسيه
العابره للقارات هندسه خاصه بالصواريخ كما
يحتاج لخبره متطوره كما يقول الخبراء
تحمل صواريخ الباليسيه انظمه توجيه داخليه
تسمح لها بمغادره الغلاف الجوي ثم دخوله
لضرب اهداف محدده على الارض عندما يطلق
قمر اصطناعي ينقله الصاروخ الى مدار معين
ثم ينفصل عنه ويسقط على الارض او في البحر
على شكل وابل من الحضن
يقول خبراء انه فيما يتعلق بالصواريخ
الباليسير عابره للقارات فان اتقان
التقنيات اعاده الدخول الى الغلاف الجوي
امر ضروري بضمان عدم احتراق راس حربيه قبل
بلوغ هدفها ولكن بالنسبه الى الصواريخ
التي تحمل اقمرا اصطناعيه فان هذا النوع
من التكنولوجيا التي تسمح بدخول الغلاف
الجوي ليس ضروريا وفي الاخير يشير
المحللون الى ان الاختبار الذي اجري
الاربعاء يظهر رغبه كوريا الشماليه في
دخول عصر الفضاء العسكري قبل جارتها
الجنوبيه والمتوقع ان تطلق اول قمر
اصطناعي مخصص فقط للتطبيقات العسكريه
بحلول نهايه العام وذلك بواسطه صاروخ سبيس
اكس
من مدينه
اكسترا ينضم الينا في جنوب غرب انجلترا
ينضم الينا ايضا فوستر كارتور الباحث
المختص بشؤون
الكوريه في جامعه ليدز مرحبا بك سيد فرصه
بالمعنى
الاستراتيجي السياسي لكوريا الشماليه ماذا
يعني ان تفشل هذه المره هي سادس مره
ان تفشل ايضا هذه المره كوريا في اطلاق
صاروخ مخصص لاغراض التجسس العسكري
الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن موضوع عن جديا
للغايه ومحرج للغايه ما من احد يحدد الفشل
وطبعا كوريا الشماليه لا تحدد الفشل
يمكننا ان نعود الى مرحله بدات منذ 25
عاما بالنسبه الى البرنامج الصاروخي
البالستي الكوري الشمالي
وحاولت بشكل متكرر كوريا الشماليه ان تطلق
هذا القمر الاصطناعي وهذا مصدر احراج ان
يحدث هذا الفشل وهنا كما اشرتم في تقريركم
الى سلسله من
التقنيات التي كوريا الشماليه بحاجه اليها
بالنسبه الى اعاده الحصول على الصواريخ
الباليستيه في حال كان تود ان تعود الحس
بالحصول عليها ولكن انا متاكد من انها سوف
تحاول ان تعيد الكره بعد اسبوعين او ثلاثه
اسابيع لكن ما الذي سيختلف بعد اسبوعين او
ثلاثه يعني هل هل يمكن ان يكون ذلك مجرد
خطا ام هي لا تمتلك التقنيات الضروريه
لاتمام هذه المهمه بنجاح اطلاق صاروخ
لتثبيت قمر اصطناعي للتجسس
يمكن ان تكون على حق بالنسبه الى هذا
الموضوع نحن نتحدث عن استراتيجيه فيها
مخاطر مرتفعه هناك برنامج للصواريخ
الباليستيه باضافه الى الاسلحه الهجوميه
بقياده كيمجون بدا المشروع لاحدى عشره سنه
كان هناك بعض النجاحات ولكن بشكل عام
لديهم النظام الذي يمكن ان يصل الى قاره
الامريكيه ولكن في هذه المره شاهدنا على
هذا الفشل هناك تقنيات فيها ضعف وشاهدنا
هذا الضعف بشكل متكرر ولكن هناك عامل
المفاجاه دائما مع كوريا الشماليه نحن لا
نعرف ما الذي سوف تطلقه كوريا الشماليه في
هذه المره تقول كوريا الشماليه انه من
حقها ان تقوم بعمليه اطلاق هذا وفي هذه
المره قامت
الجنوبيه في حين فشلت كوريا الشماليه ماذا
يعني ذلك سياسيا بموازين القوى في المنطقه
باختصار
احاول ان اكون مقتضبا نحن نتحدث عن
المستقبل في هذا السؤال ولكن كوريا
الجنوبيه قامت بذلك في الماضي في الاسبوع
الماضي في حقيقه الامر وهناك التقدم كبير
في كوريا الجنوبيه بهذا الخصوص بدعم من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لان كوريا
الجنوبيه تعتمد على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن ليس لدينا وقت لكي نغوص في
تفاصيل هذا الموضوع شكرا لك ايضا فوستر
كارتر كنت معنا من مدينه اكستر الباحث
المختص بشؤون الكوريه في جامعه الليز شكرا
جزيلا لك